liberal city mayors getting a tiny taste
of biden's border crisis are now crying
for help new video shows the first bus
of migrants arriving in new york city
from texas courtesy of governor greg
abbott who calls it the quote ideal
destination new york city mayor eric
adams declaring an emergency in response
to 4 000 asylum seekers coming to the
big apple over the past three months and
claims his city is being overwhelmed but
according to abbott that is not even
close to what texas is dealing with
public officials across the country they
do need to realize the magnitude of the
chaos created by biden's open border
policies there have been arms about a
few thousand people coming into their
communities over the past few months
listen in any one sector in the state of
texas we have more than 5 000 people
come across that sector every single day
and so listen we're full in the state of
texas our communities are overrun and i
started busting people to washington d.c
when
local officials could not handle the
number of people that had come across
our border
mayor adams slamming texas after
declining multiple invitations to come
witness the crisis firsthand
things as
a political
play is it's just he finally admitted
what we were saying
and uh we're going to continue to be
open arms this is who we are as a city
and we just need help from the federal
government we have a we're having a
great conversation
this afternoon with the federal
government
uh to figure out how we can get this
right but it is despicable what we're
witnessing in texas
and if you're wondering why we have a
record surge at the border listen to who
the migrants are thanking in exclusive
footage airing tonight on jesse waters
prime time
what is your message to joe biden we are
completely grateful for the opportunity
that he has given us thanks for the
support to all the venezuelans coming
here
all right so uh
i saw you lawrence laughing as i was
laughing you know you've got mayor adams
today i think there were 50 who came in
on a bus and they're having a connection
uh they're having a commission
connection and they're saying it's a
political ploy by governor greg abbott
the bottom line is that now they're
seeing what's happening in border towns
for the first time and they don't like
it well it's the reality of what's been
happening in texas for a very long time
and by the way that there are more
people that come across the border in
texas in a day than what were dropped
off uh in new york today but how do we
get to this point
uh mayor adams accused greg abbott of
doing this before he was even doing it
uh you remember judge when those same
migrants when we followed their plane
when it landed uh in new york city and
we followed it all away in jersey and
they called the police on our camera
crew because they didn't want us to see
in westchester okay so when they were
coming to new york those migrants uh you
know adams gave this press conference
and said these people are coming from
texas they weren't coming from texas the
biden administration were busting people
and flying them in and they were
dropping them off in local communities
and so he was going after abbott about
this and so abby said okay you want him
you want him from texas you want to make
us the enemy and he shipped them there
but i think right now what it's doing
right now is highlighting hypocrisy
uh from the left they were all about
compassion and giving them handouts and
welcoming them in the country until they
were on their lawns it was fine when it
was conservative areas where all the
migrants are going and now it's
affecting them they don't care about it
they're pros and 80 billion dollars
right now for 87 000 new irs agents how
about you send that money to the border
for those uh men and women that are
trying to keep us safe on a day-to-day
basis you know sandra new york city is a
sanctuary city shouldn't mayor adams
just take him if you're a sanctuary city
why don't you just bear the burden that
sanctuary cities bear and the irony of
that is he told greg abbott the solution
be you should just provide housing for
these migrants it was almost hard to
believe that was the solution that he
offered i have to think watching this
you think okay if the idea is that this
is a political
ploy or a photo op if some of these
democrats have made it out to be you
think that eric adams would just say you
know try to take care of it take them in
deal with it the best that they possibly
can with the resources at hand and say
what are you guys complaining about down
in texas you have to you have to think
that it's gotten so bad
that he can't even just take care of it
to say hey you guys aren't dealing doing
it right we've been able to manage it
here these are the numbers though
christopher wray in that hearing
yesterday talking about the significant
security issue of these border crossings
when
director mayorkas was asked about the
border
he made the
frankly from my standpoint and plausible
statement that the border was secure
from your
from your vantage point in your opinion
is the border secure
well look i i think uh the border
presents significant uh security issues
there's a wide array of criminal threats
that we encounter uh down at the border
to me it represents a significant
security issue and represents a wide
array of criminal threats that flow out
of it
sandra i mean you're talking about 50
people whose names appeared on the
federal terrorism watch list between
november and may that were identified in
those bus bus that are now expected to
soar beyond the record 1.7 million
encounters last year right now at 1.6 on
pace to pass that so while this might be
a photo op uh fine it's not not reality
that's the reality of the situation out
at the border you know the amazing part
of it jessica is that when mayor adams
asked the federal government for help
federal government says no you're going
to have to deal with it and then i think
it was bowser who asked for uh
some national guard to come in and they
said no
why all of a sudden are they now
experiencing now that they know what
it's like and they're not getting in
response why are they going after the
republican governors as opposed to the
president who's letting them in and
making us all suffer oh good idea go
after your own party when there are
republicans available everyone's going
to go after the other president who
controls the border
he's a democrat and it's easy to go out
no no it's not about partying
talking about i'm telling you on the
border
yes holistically of course the border is
a bipartisan issue i'm saying that
people politic no matter what it is an
ugly facet of life here and we've all
witnessed it you've seen people you
would say that makes it right would you
no and i didn't i just explained why
he's going after
governor abbott instead of for calling
out joe you're saying they're being
political yeah they're not looking for
the american people then
okay so there are politics going on
we've now acknowledged that we
acknowledge that i don't think it's a
good thing what's going on we also
should acknowledge what mayor adams said
in that video which is we are a
welcoming city i just need some help and
the biden administration should be
providing it our
shelter system got overrun by the first
batch it was four thousand migrants came
here we don't have enough vets for them
we don't have enough space for them we
are a sanctuary city and it would
behoove the biden administration to live
up to their talk about this and give the
money to dc and give it to new york if
you think that we have enough space for
them we have the jobs for them and make
sure that they can do that and then
don't forget the schools
sure we lost it we lost millions of
public schools
in texas she would give the money to
texas that
we don't need american taxpayer dollars
that's been taken by the federal
government to go to these cities who
have proclaimed themselves sanctuary
cities so that their constituents and
their residents don't feel the pain and
don't vote them out of office for making
it a sanctuary city to begin with it's
easy to be a sanctuary city when you're
a city of seven million people
until what a thousand people show up and
now you're overran that doesn't make any
sense at all here's what's funny to me
why is it that they think that
washington dc can't handle this but san
antonio can why is it they think that
new york city can't handle this but
houston should this is a core issue in
this country that says i went to war and
lost my legs for the citizens of this
country not mexico or guatemala or
anywhere else doesn't mean i harbor any
ill will towards them but the citizens
in this country come first that's where
the sacrifice was that's where the money
comes from that's who we are that's our
identity as americans and if there are
people from other countries that want to
be a part of this then our politicians
need to be held accountable in creating
a system that allows them to in a way
that protects us first and offers them
opportunity second i come from a city of
this i've seen this i've seen people
t-boned my sister jump out of the car
and take off running next week they're
at work with a different identity
because they never had papers to begin
with whether or not that makes them a
good or a bad person it makes our
government bad for letting them do that
there is a intricate
decades-old system for fraudulent
identities in this country when you
bring someone in and you say come back
in two years you know what they've had
three identities in those two years
that's what is fraud that's what
defrauds us it's not about empathy as
you can see with eric adams right now
it's not about empathy at all it's about
oh man now it's my problem and now i
could be politically held accountable we
better do something about this that's
what's wrong and the people who are hurt
worse from this are those who do come
here illegally and live in the shadows
and never have a chance to be a part of
what is the american dream which they
thought they were coming here for
because our government both sides of the
aisle would rather keep this method
because it benefits them in some way
here or there rather than what benefits
us as americans what should joe biden do
quickly he should give out federal funds
to places where these migrants are going
he should work on border security last
week they started closing up that big
gap in yuma that's right yeah you know
what the interesting thing is the last
time we had this conversation here you
said that greg abbott's stunt did not
work is it working now
the stunt we were talking about was when
he was holding up the inspections
when he sent the bus to d.c you said it
didn't work now it's become a
nationalistic
irresponsibility
all of the cities now i don't think that
guys guys
childish and still treating migrants as
if they're just toys that you throw on a
bus and you ship off you know what i
don't know how about you guys close the
border and if you're killed and then
this will joe biden is treating them
like toys joe biden is the one who's
treating them as though they need to be
protected they need health care
education medication and everything else
while we pay through the nose for it we
can't afford it new york city can't
afford it texas towns can't afford it
washington can't afford to end it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else